Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Have you ever wondered in what subtle ways we might be harming our own physical or
这些原则都同样适用。挑战中还有丽莎亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。你是否曾想过，我们可能在哪些细微的方面伤害了自己的身体或
mental well-being? There's a concept called indirect self-harm which doesn't get a lot of press but I think it's time to turn that on its head. There are so many behaviours that can be classified as indirect self-harm. Come along, tune in and see whether you might be able to improve your well-being or that of someone that you are working with too. Hope you find it so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I am so delighted to be able to talk with you today with our guest expert for the day about a topic that you might not have considered before. I think it's especially relevant that we talk about indirect self-harm for aspiring
心理健康？有一个概念叫“间接自残”，虽然媒体报道不多，但我认为现在是时候重新审视它了。有许多行为都可以归类为间接自残。欢迎收听本期节目，看看你是否能改善自己或你所帮助之人的身心健康。希望这对你有帮助。欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天我非常高兴能与我们的客座专家一起探讨一个你可能从未考虑过的话题。我认为探讨“间接自残”对于有抱负的
psychologists as well who might be pushing themselves to the brink of exhaustion and applying all sorts of pressures to themselves too. I hope that you will find this episode to be a really thought-provoking, inspiring, helpful listen. I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Just want to welcome along our guest for today Eva Perry hi hi thanks for having me on oh thank you so much for um being so um happy to talk to us so it won't surprise anybody listening to this podcast that our paths crossed on LinkedIn didn't they yes yeah I posted about um I started making some information booklets and I think they've got some attention from the community, which is nice to see. Yeah. So you are a psychology undergraduate and you're doing your psychology masters at the moment. Yeah, so I'm a postgraduate in my master's course so I've um had my undergraduate degree in psychology um and now
心理学家来说尤为重要，因为他们可能正把自己逼到精疲力竭的边缘，并承受着各种各样的压力。希望这一集能让你深思、受到启发，并有所收获。节目结束后我们再交流。现在欢迎我们今天的嘉宾伊娃·佩里（Eva Perry）。你好，谢谢你邀请我。哦，非常感谢你愿意来和我们交流。听众们一定不会感到惊讶，我们是在领英（LinkedIn）上结识的，对吧？是的，我发布了一些关于我制作的信息手册的内容，很高兴看到它们引起了社区的关注。是的。你现在是一名心理学本科生，同时也在攻读心理学硕士学位。是的，我目前是硕士课程的研究生，我本科获得了心理学学位，现在
I'm in my master's for clinical child psychology so yeah really enjoying it. I hope that is going really well for you and your undergraduate research project was on the concept of indirect self-harm is that right? yeah that's right it was a really new uh topic when I was looking um through different ideas the idea actually came to me um I was doing I had a placement year in my degree and I did a couple level two courses just alongside that and one of them was in self-harm and suicide prevention. And they talked about indirect suicide, which led into indirect self-harm. And I thought it was so interesting. I've never heard of this kind of concept before.
正在攻读临床儿童心理学硕士，真的很喜欢这个专业。希望你的学业一切顺利。你的本科研究课题是关于“间接自残”的概念，对吗？是的，没错。当我寻找研究课题时，这是一个非常新的话题。这个想法其实是在我做实习的那一年产生的，当时我顺便修了几门二级课程，其中一门是关于自残和自杀预防的。他们提到了“间接自杀”，这引出了“间接自残”的概念。我觉得这太有趣了，以前从未听说过这个概念。
So it was a perfect opportunity to do some further research while I had the opportunity. Okay. So indirect suicide is when somebody has meant to hurt themselves, but hasn't meant to end their own life. Is that right? Potentially, yeah. There's loads of different kind of ways it can happen. So whether it comes from medical neglect, for example, if someone has diabetes and they're neglecting their medication and then they end up passing away because of that. Or someone engaging in something really risky and they don't mean to end up dying from it, but they're aware of the risk or those sort of activities. Yeah. And in terms of death certificates I'm
所以，这是一个利用现有机会进行深入研究的绝佳时机。好的。那么，间接自杀是指某人有意伤害自己，但并非真的想结束自己的生命，是这样吗？有可能，是的。这种情况有很多种发生方式。例如，源于医疗疏忽，如果某人患有糖尿病却忽视服药，最终因此去世。或者某人参与了非常危险的活动，虽然无意死亡，但他们意识到其中的风险，诸如此类。是的。关于死亡证明，我
thinking that's sometimes put down to death by misadventure as well yeah exactly yeah would that be indirect suicide would that be a cause of death that you're aware of or would it always be sort of a medical cause of death that's used you know so for example it's something to do with the brain or the head or the heart or you know what's your understanding of that yeah I'm not entirely well versed on on how that would come up on a death certificate but it would probably be put down as an accident of some kind um yeah yeah sorry to put you on the spot, but it's just the way my brain works and it's like, oh, what would happen there? OK, so tell us a little bit then about indirect self-harm, because that's a really interesting area in itself and so interesting that you did your research on it. Yeah, yeah. So basically the concept of indirect self-harm is it's there's several different definitions because it's such a new theory.
想到有时会被归类为“意外死亡”，对吧？是的，完全正确。那这算间接自杀吗？这是你所了解的死亡原因吗？还是说通常会使用某种医学上的死因？比如与大脑、头部或心脏有关的？你是怎么理解的？是的，我不太清楚死亡证明上会如何表述，但很可能会被归类为某种意外。抱歉让你措手不及，这只是我的思维方式，我在想如果发生这种情况会怎样。好的，那给我们讲讲“间接自残”吧，这本身就是一个非常有趣的领域，你以此作为研究课题真是太棒了。好的。基本上，“间接自残”这个概念有几种不同的定义，因为它是一个非常新的理论。
But the main one I really liked was that they it's an activity that might cause unintended harm. So it's you know, it's not deliberate seeking out harm. For example, when people self-harm they might cut themselves that's a very deliberate and highly visible form of hurting yourself which those two aspects tend to be what many professionals say makes self-harm is it being highly visible and it being deliberate so with indirect self-harm it might be things like social isolation or sleep deprivation you know just not looking after yourself so it's not necessarily uh seeking out that harm intentionally but it comes around as um a secondary effect of what you're doing
但我最喜欢的一个定义是：它是一种可能导致非预期伤害的行为。也就是说，它不是刻意寻求伤害。例如，当人们自残时，他们可能会割伤自己，这是一种非常刻意且高度可见的伤害方式。许多专业人士认为，高度可见和刻意为之是自残的两个核心特征。而对于间接自残，它可能是社交孤立或睡眠剥夺，仅仅是不照顾好自己。所以，它不一定是刻意寻求伤害，而是你所做行为的次生影响。
yeah really interesting so actually a lot of the stuff that we might kind of see as kind of self-neglect like not eating not taking care of yourself like sometimes not even showering not um you know not picking up your dirty socks off the floor um can potentially lead to kind of sanitation hygiene issues for yourself or issues of malnourishment that are that are about often about motivation about perhaps very low mood poor self-worth you know I think sometimes there's factors involved with how many pressures you've got going on as well so I'm thinking about I'm a mother of two young children and in the times where they used to wake like 37 times a night um to wash your hair and have a
是的，非常有趣。实际上，我们看到的很多被视为“自我忽视”的行为，比如不吃饭、不照顾自己、有时甚至不洗澡、不捡起地上的脏袜子，都可能导致卫生问题或营养不良。这些往往与动力不足、情绪低落、自我价值感低有关。我认为有时也与你承受的压力有关。比如，作为两个年幼孩子的母亲，在他们晚上醒来37次的时候，去洗头、洗澡，你会觉得有意义吗？因为你已经累到骨子里了，感觉身体被掏空了。但同时，我也想到那些需要额外照顾伴侣、孩子或父母的人，
shower and feel that there's any point in doing that you know because you're so I think about that as being bone cold tired like you just much left in the tank really you know um but also thinking about somebody who might have additional caring needs for their own partner or their children um or some you know a parent for example it's very easy to focus on meeting the needs of other people but you might do that at the detriment to yourself but actually it's a really interesting concept that technically that that is indirect self-harm yeah yeah i mean there's a massive call for for people to recognize that um those sort of behaviors you know usually they're talked about as almost a prerequisite to direct self-harm. So when it's applied in a clinical practice,
人们很容易专注于满足他人的需求，却以牺牲自己为代价。但实际上，这是一个非常有趣的概念，从技术上讲，这属于间接自残。是的，确实。人们非常呼吁大家认识到这些行为，因为它们通常被视为直接自残的先决条件。因此，当应用于临床实践时，
you might look at indirect self-harm as a potential warning sign. So that theory can help preventing escalation of those behaviours. What you're talking about as well with this kind of socially accepted kind of behaviours of indirect self-harm is the notion of culturally accepted self-harm acts which is something that a brilliant researcher Turp came up with which is I mean it is what it says on the tin so it's any behaviors that might be socially permissible so obviously doing this research I was a university student and in these environments, there's so many of these behaviours come up, you know, excessive alcohol consumption,
你可以将间接自残视为一个潜在的预警信号。该理论有助于防止这些行为升级。你刚才提到的那些社会普遍接受的间接自残行为，就是特普（Turp）这位杰出的研究人员提出的“文化认可的自残行为”。顾名思义，这就是指任何社会允许的行为。显然，在做这项研究时，我是一名大学生，在这样的环境中，会出现很多此类行为，比如过度饮酒、
experimenting with drugs, you know, self-criticism and perfectionism. These sort of behaviours are very problematic and they definitely come under the indirect self harm bracket. But they're so acceptable, you know, in university, that's just something that everyone does. It's almost like a rite of passage. So I think there's definitely as well, very interesting looking at that, from, you know, as I was living it, to be researching that, yeah, it's interesting. It really is interesting. um I'm married and
尝试毒品、自我批评和完美主义。这些行为非常有问题，绝对属于间接自残的范畴。但在大学里，这些行为太普遍了，每个人都这样做，几乎就像一种“成人礼”。所以，从我亲身经历并进行研究的角度来看，这确实非常有趣。确实非常有趣。我结婚了，
I'm married to somebody who's currently I think he's 48 yes winding him up about almost being 49 um and one of his favorite food groups which isn't even a food group is sugar um he likes cakes he likes sweets he likes apple juice. He likes Pepsi. But he's in really good shape because actually over the last few years, he's been kind of doing some strength training and kind of doing all that jazz. And it's always been, even since I met him, he's always been heavily into sugar, but he's been long and thin like a bean. And it's like, I don't really get how you're managing that but actually it was interesting when he went to the doctor to the dentist about seven or eight months ago she was like something is not right here you know your teeth essentially are not not managing very well you know she said are you sick a lot and he was like no and I he came home and
我丈夫今年48岁，我常拿他快49岁开玩笑。他最喜欢的食物类别之一（甚至算不上食物类别）是糖。他喜欢蛋糕、糖果、苹果汁和百事可乐。但他身材很好，因为过去几年他一直在做力量训练之类的运动。从我认识他起，他就一直很爱吃糖，但他一直像豆芽菜一样又高又瘦。我真的不明白他是怎么做到的。但有趣的是，大约七八个月前他去看牙医时，牙医说：“这里有点不对劲，你的牙齿状况很糟糕。”她问他：“你经常呕吐吗？”他回答没有。他回家后
told me and I said I think she's trying to ask gently whether you are bulimic whether you're making yourself sick because she's kind of concerned about the level of acid erosion on your teeth and when he went back again the next week you know that he explored that with her and she said and he said I think it's maybe I drink a lot of sugary drinks. You know, actually, all of the stuff I drink. So is tea, he has tea with three sugars. And, you know, he'll murder me for talking so publicly about him. He's quite private.
告诉了我，我说：“我觉得她是在委婉地问你是否患有贪食症，是否在催吐，因为她担心你牙齿的酸蚀程度。”当他下周再去复诊时，他与牙医探讨了这个问题。他说：“我想可能是因为我喝了很多含糖饮料。”实际上，我喝的所有东西都是茶，他喝茶要加三勺糖。他如果知道我这么公开谈论他，一定会杀了我的，他很注重隐私。
Sorry, babe. But it's an interesting conversation. You know, it was having an impact on his teeth. So we've now invested in a waterpik flosser. He is now drinking more sugar-free squash. He's not drinking apple juice. He's swilling his mouth out after drinking Pepsi. You know, so he's still not perfect.
抱歉，亲爱的。但这确实是一个有趣的对话。你知道，这确实影响了他的牙齿。所以我们现在买了一个冲牙器。他现在喝更多的无糖果汁，不喝苹果汁了，喝完百事可乐后会漱口。所以，他仍然不够完美。
But I think he just hadn't quite realised that even that constitutes indirect self-harm. Yeah, definitely. I mean, that's a brilliant example of it, where it's not the direct intention to be hurting yourself in that way. You know, these effects, they come up as an accumulation of behaviours or, you know, persistent behaviours. I do sympathise because I have a sweet tooth myself um but yeah it's it's that's a really good example of it for sure I'll let him know that it was clinically relevant and approved
但我认为他只是没意识到这构成了间接自残。是的，绝对是。这是一个绝佳的例子，因为这并非直接伤害自己的意图。这些影响是行为积累或持续行为的结果。我很同情，因为我自己也爱吃甜食，但这确实是一个很好的例子。我会让他知道这在临床上是相关的，并且得到了认可。
okay so yeah like this is a big topic and it's it's a really broad public health conversation but is this that we need to be getting better at psychoeducation how can we have a a role for this um you know many of the people listening to this will be working in mental health services either as aspiring psychologists um or you know maybe even qualified ones too we've got some qualified listeners how can we help to think about this with the people that we work with? Yeah I think it's really a matter of awareness I mean when I was researching this for my undergraduate there was I mean I could count how many papers were on indirect self-harm on one hand it was really under-researched and so I think having that awareness can be massively helpful as I said earlier it can help with noticing early signs that may be leading to you know direct self-harming
好的，这是一个很大的话题，也是一个非常广泛的公共卫生议题。我们需要在心理教育方面做得更好吗？我们能发挥什么作用？听众中许多人都在心理健康服务部门工作，无论是作为有抱负的心理学家，还是已经合格的心理学家，我们该如何帮助我们所服务的人？是的，我认为这主要是一个意识问题。我在做本科研究时，关于间接自残的论文屈指可数，研究非常不足。所以我认为，提高这种意识非常有帮助。正如我之前所说，它可以帮助识别可能导致直接自残的早期迹象。
behaviours in clinical practice to notice those signs and kind of catch it before it escalates um and obviously the example um with your partner it's um the the concern that it might be an eating disorder it's a bit contentious but um in indirect self-harm i believe that eating disorders do come under that um because it's it might not be the um the direct intention to be causing harm to your body. For example, with bulimia, you do get tooth erosion and those sort of effects. They're not doing that for that effect that they might be doing it because they have low self-esteem or they want to look a certain way so um i do think it's important to sort of catch those behaviors before they might escalate into a full-blown eating disorder for example or um you know other yeah negative uh behaviors it's really important to have that awareness
在临床实践中，识别这些迹象并及时干预，防止其升级。当然，关于你伴侣的例子，担心这可能是饮食失调，这有点争议。但我认为饮食失调属于间接自残，因为这可能不是直接伤害身体的意图。例如，贪食症会导致牙齿侵蚀等后果。他们这样做可能不是为了这种效果，而是因为自尊心低或想达到某种外貌。所以我认为在这些行为升级为严重的饮食失调或其他负面行为之前及时发现它们非常重要。拥有这种意识非常关键。
yeah so i think often when i'm working with people with um bulimia specifically, the tooth erosion takes a while generally. But the things with kind of acid reflux and difficulty kind of keeping food down, even when you intend to, that happens a little quicker because of the way that the muscles and things work. So you can lead to lasting changes in your body because of you know bulimia is horrendous for people and it's it's a hugely distressing situation so you know there's a variety of reasons why it crops up and we know that it's a coping mechanism for you know a variety of challenging things but um you know these are not um not things that people do lightly nor are they that easy to to overcome but there are consequences for your physical health for your mental health
是的，我认为在处理贪食症患者时，牙齿侵蚀通常需要一段时间。但酸反流和难以留住食物的问题，即使是无意的，也会因为肌肉功能的原因发生得更快。这会导致身体的持久性改变。贪食症对患者来说是极其痛苦的，情况非常令人沮丧。所以，它出现的原因多种多样，我们知道它是应对各种挑战的应对机制。但这些行为并非人们轻率所为，也不容易克服，它们会对你的身心健康造成后果。
and um yeah i think indirect self-harm is such such an interesting area definitely and on that point as well um one of the main things that differentiates it from direct self-harm is that with indirect self-harming behaviors they usually lead on to other indirect self-harming behaviors um so for example with eating disorders you might um then you know if you're not eating you might not be sleeping well, you might be neglecting a personal hygiene because of that. So you have this sort of knock on effect that you don't see necessarily with direct self-harm. Usually there'll be one form of self-harm and then it doesn't impact so much developing another form of direct self-harm. With the research I did, we found that the average amount of indirect self-harming
是的，我认为间接自残是一个非常有趣的领域。另外，区分它与直接自残的主要一点是，间接自残行为通常会引发其他间接自残行为。例如，在饮食失调中，如果你不吃饭，可能睡眠不好，也可能因此忽视个人卫生。这种连锁反应在直接自残中并不一定能看到。通常，直接自残往往表现为一种形式，而不会轻易引发另一种形式。在我的研究中，我们发现平均每人每月有10到12种间接自残行为，所以种类非常多。
behaviors we saw was 10 to 12 um in a month so it's a very big variety that that you get to see yeah what's your top 12 12 might be too many to ask you to list off but what are people most often reporting um the top three were i believe yes having self-defeating thoughts comfort eating and declining to ask for help when they were struggling um emotionally or physically oh gosh that is you know number three is especially interesting for me and i think it very much weaves in with perfectionism and that desire you know that that desire, you know, that belief that, you know, you can't ask for help or you shouldn't ask for help. And actually what I know now as a mother, you know, my youngest is now very almost eight. He's eagerly planning his
是的，你提到的前12种是什么？列举太多可能太难了，但人们报告最多的是什么？我想前三名是：自我挫败的想法、情绪化进食，以及在情感或身体挣扎时拒绝寻求帮助。天哪，第三点对我来说特别有趣，我认为它与完美主义以及那种“你不能寻求帮助”或“你不应该寻求帮助”的信念紧密相连。实际上，作为一名母亲，我的小儿子快八岁了，他正热切地计划着他的
eighth birthday party and list. I wish that I'd taken the help that was offered for me, but I also wish I'd asked for more help you know when people came around to say you know cuddle the baby I wish I'd said actually can I have a nap you take baby for a walk around the block in the push chair or in the sling or actually when you're in the bathroom would you mind just staying behind for five minutes and cleaning it for me and there's not a single one of my friends that would have said no they would have been happy to help but I didn't know it was okay to ask for that help and I remember when I had my eldest who is approaching 11 he doesn't like me to say he's 10 I was in a different home to this one and he was asleep on my shoulder and because
八岁生日派对。我真希望当时能接受别人提供的帮助，也希望自己能多寻求帮助。当人们来看我并说“抱抱宝宝”时，我真希望我说：“其实我能睡一会儿吗？你带宝宝推着车或背着带在街区走走好吗？”或者当你在洗手间时，你介意帮我清理一下吗？我的朋友们没有一个人会拒绝，他们会很乐意帮忙，但我当时不知道寻求这种帮助是可以的。我记得我大儿子快11岁了，他不让我说他才10岁。当时我住在另一所房子里，他睡在我的肩膀上。因为
I got so little sleep when they were asleep I was very reluctant to put them down and my babies like to wake up as soon as you put them down anyway. And I was looking at the board that was gradually getting more and more covered in dust and just thinking, I want that dusted. I'm not particularly house proud, but it got to the stage where it really needed doing like probably three months ago. And I was like, I'm not going to get a chance to do that because when I have a spare moment the last thing I'm going to want to do is to dust that skirting board but I wish I'd just said to somebody you know I probably didn't even say to my husband you dust that skirting board because I felt that pressure to be the perfect housewife the perfect mother to have a clean home we had a brand new build property at that time as well which probably didn't help because everything looked so shiny and white and so then you notice those small changes but
他们睡觉时我睡眠很少，所以我很不情愿放下他们。而且我的宝宝无论如何一放下就会醒。我看着那块逐渐积满灰尘的踢脚线，心想：“我真想把它擦干净。”我并不是特别爱整洁，但它已经到了三个月前就该清理的地步了。我心想：“我没机会做这个，因为我有空闲时间时，最不想做的事就是擦踢脚线。”但我真希望我当时能对某人说，我可能甚至没对丈夫说：“你擦一下踢脚线。”因为我感到要成为完美主妇、完美母亲、拥有干净房子的压力。当时我们住的是新房，这可能也没什么帮助，因为一切看起来都那么闪亮洁白，所以你会注意到那些细小的变化。
yeah yeah I'm just it's really interesting to to hear you say that that's the top three is not offering help that's offered to you or not asking for help that really resonates with me yeah I mean that's thank you for sharing that that's definitely an interesting uh story as well coming into that subject so um I think it comes back to what's culturally acceptable so uni students you know you're kind of expected to have those behaviors and I'm not a mother myself but um you know my sister's a mother and kind of seeing her experiences is you're kind of expected to have that that difficult time people always say oh you know my sister's a mother and kind of seeing her experiences is you're kind of expected to have that that difficult time people always say oh you know terrible tears watch out um and there's
是的，听到你说前三名是“不接受提供的帮助”或“不寻求帮助”，这真的引起了我的共鸣。是的，谢谢你的分享，这确实是一个有趣的故事。我认为这归结于什么是“文化认可的”。大学生被期望有这些行为。我不是母亲，但我姐姐是，看到她的经历，你会觉得你被期望经历那段艰难时期。人们总是说：“哦，天哪，小心点。”而且
sort of that expectation that it's going to be horrible so you might not feel uh perhaps that you you should be asking for help because you know this is just how it's supposed to be I think that definitely plays into a lot of the papers that we see yeah I think it's one of the beautiful things about this podcast and also lovely nourishing books is that it helps you think oh I didn't realize that I've never thought about that or actually you know I might use that or do that differently in future so I wish that when I'd visited my friends with new babies that I'd said so i brought my mini vac with me i'm just gonna he's okay i'm just gonna i'm just gonna just gonna whip it around for you because actually you think that and like there's no shame in that is it we're not trying to shame people
有一种预期，认为这会很糟糕，所以你可能觉得不应该寻求帮助，因为“这本来就是这样”。我认为这在很多论文中都有体现。是的，我认为这个播客和那些滋养心灵的书籍的美妙之处在于，它能让你思考：“我以前没意识到，我从未想过这一点。”或者“未来我可能会以不同的方式使用或处理它。”所以我希望当我去探望有新生儿的朋友时，我说：“我带了迷你吸尘器，我帮你清理一下吧。”这没什么可羞耻的，我们不是要羞辱别人，
we're trying to say actually when i come around i really want to be as useful to you as i can you know and actually if you don't need me to bring three brand new baby grows from next, you know, can I bring you some home cooked meals that you put in the freezer that are going to really nourish you. And actually, when my friend was pregnant with her third child, she had her first baby, sadly, her second was stillborn, she was really thinking about the birth of her third baby. And rather than baby things, she said, could you cook me your favourite meals, put them in some freezable containers. And then when I met up with her, I bought her a really lovely cool bag, I'd put some like little kind of cold freeze things in there. And that's what she, you know, existed on when her baby was little.
我们是想说：“当你来看我时，我真的想尽可能为你提供帮助。”如果你不需要我带三件新的婴儿连体衣，我可以为你做一些冷冻餐，让你吃得更有营养。我朋友怀第三个孩子时，她的第一个孩子还在，第二个不幸死产了。她当时很担心第三个孩子的出生。她没要婴儿用品，而是说：“你能做你最拿手的菜，放在冷冻盒里吗？”见面时，我送了她一个漂亮的保温包，里面放了冰袋。这就是她宝宝小时候赖以生存的食物。
You know, all of this made with love, really nutritious. She knows I like vegetables. So she knew that that would be, you know, food with love. And to know that actually a time when you're going to be struggling, for example, I lost my dad and that was a really challenging time for probably the two years after that and when he was unwell I wish I'd asked for more help and accepted more help at that time but it's only really when we de-shame ourselves and when we go through adversity and then learn compassion that we know it's okay to ask for help it's not it doesn't say anything
这些都是充满爱心、非常有营养的食物。她知道我喜欢蔬菜，所以她知道那是充满爱心的食物。在挣扎的时候，比如我父亲去世后的两年里，那是一段非常艰难的时光。当他生病时，我真希望当时能寻求并接受更多帮助。但只有当我们不再感到羞耻，经历过逆境并学会同情时，我们才知道寻求帮助是可以的。这并不能说明你
bad about you to do that yeah I 100% agree it's so important to surround yourself with those positive people I think a lot of times people you surround yourself with can facilitate those sort of behaviors so you know as a uni student if you're surrounding yourself with people who are experimenting a lot with drugs or you know promiscuity alcoholism that those sort of behavior so you know as a uni student if you're surrounding yourself with people who are experimenting a lot with drugs or you know promiscuity alcoholism that those sort of behaviors it's easy to get drawn into that so it's so important to have that supportive network it sounds like you were absolutely brilliant to your friend it's i'm just definitely you know grateful to have you for that um yeah it's it's a really important thing the thing with indirect self-harm is because it's so under research there's not many um kind of interventions for it
有什么不好。是的，我100%同意。周围有积极的人非常重要。我认为很多时候，你身边的人会促成这些行为。作为大学生，如果你身边的人都在尝试毒品、滥交或酗酒，你很容易被卷入其中。所以拥有一个支持性的网络非常重要。你对你的朋友真是太好了，我很感激有你。是的，这真的很重要。间接自残的问题在于，因为它研究不足，所以没有太多
um as such out there so um yeah we've kind of got to think about those sort of um you know preventative and protective factors in in terms of reducing those behaviors i think support networks is a massive one yeah yeah and because it is so new are there any outcome measures that yet screen for indirect self-harm yes so um there's one that i used for my undergraduate research, which is the direct and indirect self-harm inventory. And actually, interestingly, the first self-harm measure that you're probably familiar with, the self-harm inventory actually had quite a few indirect self-harming behaviors on it anyway, which I think is good. good so for my undergraduate um project I merged those two together to get a list of um indirect self-harming behaviors that people could you know rate how often they engage in those so it'd be items like um you know driving recklessly or exercising when you're injured or um yeah those sort of behaviors is it's uh it's very limited measures but we do have a couple
干预措施。所以我们必须考虑预防和保护因素，以减少这些行为。我认为支持网络是一个巨大的因素。是的，因为这是一个新领域，目前有任何筛查间接自残的评估量表吗？有的，我在本科研究中使用了一个，叫“直接和间接自残量表”。有趣的是，你可能熟悉的第一个自残量表——“自残量表”——本身就包含了不少间接自残行为，这很好。所以为了本科项目，我将两者合并，列出了一份人们可以评估自己参与频率的间接自残行为清单。比如
really good ones yeah and that's another interesting one isn't it one of my besties um has got into marathons and half marathons and um all sorts of fitness in the last couple of years and every time she runs she ends up with like runs for a distance she runs up she ends up with a problem with her knee and i'm like baby girl i think your body is saying i really want you to run and she's like no it's telling me it wants me to run more and i'm like i'm not so sure about that my love but it's really difficult things we want to do our body doesn't necessarily like and it's interesting to think about that as self-harm yeah 100 it's being mindful of um you know what your body's telling you i think it's mindfulness with i mean it's in most different therapies and counseling it's and that's for a
鲁莽驾驶或受伤时坚持锻炼等行为。虽然量表很有限，但我们确实有几个不错的。是的，这也是一个有趣的例子。我的一位闺蜜过去几年迷上了马拉松和半程马拉松，各种健身。每次她跑完一段距离，膝盖就会出问题。我说：“亲爱的，我觉得你的身体在说‘我真的很想让你跑’。”她说：“不，它是在告诉我，它想让我跑得更多。”我说：“我不太确定，亲爱的。”但我们想做的事情，身体未必喜欢，把这看作自残很有趣。是的，100%。要留意身体告诉你的信息。我认为这是正念，大多数疗法和咨询中都有，这是有
reason it's so important to be in tune with your um you know the physical sensations and and um you know for example certain indirect self-harm behaviors can be uh just picking your nails um my partner has this habit where he'll pick his cuticles and it'll it's oh i feel it looks so painful um and it counts as indirect self-harm because you're causing harm to yourself but it's not the direct intention of it and so those sort of behaviours it's important to be mindful of when you're doing that and to kind of catch yourself from doing that
原因的。与身体感觉保持一致非常重要。例如，某些间接自残行为可能只是咬指甲。我伴侣有咬指甲周围皮肤的习惯，看起来很痛。这算间接自残，因为你在伤害自己，但不是直接意图。所以，留意这些行为并及时制止非常重要。
to kind of stop those behaviours and that's interesting because I used to nibble skin down the sides of my fingers but you know what made me stop it was when I got an adult brace in 2008 I think it was and I realized that I was pushing my front tooth and so that's probably what had led to some movement in my teeth to begin with so indirectly my nibbling my skin was also affecting my teeth so there was two types of indirect self-harm and I realized in the bath my fingers looked gross so if I was going swimming or anything my fingers looked gross and I was like I don't want to do that anymore so I'm going to put that I'm going to put that down and make a conscious
要停止这些行为。这很有趣，因为我以前也喜欢咬手指侧面的皮肤。但让我停止的是2008年我戴了成人牙套，我意识到我在推我的前牙，这可能就是导致我牙齿移位的原因。所以，我咬皮肤的行为间接影响了我的牙齿。那是两种间接自残。我在洗澡时发现手指看起来很恶心，如果我要去游泳，手指看起来很糟糕。我不想再这样了，所以我做出了一个有意识的
choice to not do that to break that cycle this is such a fascinating conversation and as we talk if people are watching on YouTube they'll be able to see that I'm drinking a cup of tea which isn't something I usually do but we're talking in the afternoon and often I'll record podcasts in the morning but I wanted to squeeze this one in because it had such an interesting topic that's relevant to kind of the trauma-y stuff that I'm talking about at the moment, but also because it's just hugely interesting. But I'm drinking a cup of green tea with lemon. And I have a cup of that every day at 1.30pm. Like I'm quite a creature of having, I tend to have lunch at the same time. And then
选择，不再那样做，打破那个循环。这是一次非常迷人的对话。如果人们在YouTube上观看，会看到我正在喝一杯茶，这不是我通常做的事，但我们是在下午录音。我通常在早上录制播客，但我还是想挤出时间录这一集，因为它的话题非常有趣，与我目前谈论的创伤话题相关，而且它本身就非常吸引人。我正在喝一杯柠檬绿茶。我每天下午1:30都会喝一杯。我是一个习惯性很强的人，通常在同一时间吃午饭。然后
as I'm preparing to come back online, it's about one o'clock, 1.30pm, I'll quite a creature I tend to have lunch at the same time and then as I'm preparing to come back online it's about one o'clock 1 30 I'll have I'll have a cup of green tea with lemon but that's the only caffeine I have all day and it's quite weak but actually if I don't have that my body is expecting it and feels a bit wobbly and caffeine can be a really big deal, can't it, in terms of indirect self-harm? Yeah, definitely. I mean, any of those sort of addictions, I suppose, people have. So whether it's smoking alcohol, caffeine, they can have a massive impact. again it's not the direct intention of it um although i would argue potentially uh green tea sounds lovely um i've got a tea drink myself but i've heard that it has quite uh calming effects and um it can be quite a positive uh you know yeah i don't think
当我准备上线时，大约是一点或一点半，我会喝一杯柠檬绿茶。这是我全天唯一的咖啡因摄入，而且很淡。但如果我不喝，身体会期待它，感觉有点不稳。咖啡因在间接自残方面确实是一个大问题，对吧？是的，绝对。任何此类成瘾，无论是吸烟、酒精还是咖啡因，都会产生巨大影响。再次强调，这并非直接意图，尽管我会说绿茶听起来很棒。我自己也喝茶，但我听说它有相当平静的效果，可以是非常积极的。我不认为
i don't think i'm a risk to myself or others with one cup of very weak tea. It's got antioxidants and good stuff in it. So I think, you know, I'm doing all right. But, you know, I am concerned about caffeine and human brains, especially young brains. So my 10 year old will often say, can I have Coke at the pub if we're going out? And I'm like, no, Coke is not a treat um it's never a good thing I know daddy drinks pepsi but it's not it's not like a rite of passage you know caffeine is the largest unregulated drug in in the world and this is not necessarily something that I want my 10 year old to have and I had a conversation about this in my private
我不认为喝一杯很淡的茶会对自己或他人造成风险。它含有抗氧化剂和好东西。所以我认为我做得还不错。但我确实担心咖啡因对人类大脑的影响，尤其是年轻的大脑。所以我10岁大的孩子经常问：“我们出去吃饭时，我可以喝可乐吗？”我说：“不，可乐不是奖励，它从来都不是好东西。”我知道爸爸喝百事可乐，但这并不是什么“成人礼”。咖啡因是世界上最大规模的未受监管的药物，我不希望我10岁的孩子摄入。我在我的私人
psychologist group as a practitioner parent as well to think about actually what are how do we explore this safely you know what I know is if we say no to kids that they potentially go off and do it to excess anyway and it's it's thinking about not making it a big deal but not necessarily having it as a treat either I don't want him to think that that coke is a treat so as we record this um we went out for a meal yesterday to celebrate the end of his sats which is quite an important rite of passage for a 10 year old and he said can I have a coke and I was like no not today baby because I will sometimes say yes but I didn't want him to think that the way we celebrate
心理学家小组中也讨论过这个问题，作为一名从业者家长，我们该如何安全地探讨这个问题？我知道如果我们对孩子说“不”，他们可能会去过度尝试。所以关键在于不要把它当成大事，但也不要把它当作奖励。我不希望他认为可乐是一种奖励。所以，在我们录音时，昨天我们出去吃饭庆祝他SAT考试结束，这对10岁孩子来说是一个重要的成人礼。他说：“我可以喝可乐吗？”我说：“不，今天不行，宝贝。”因为我有时会答应，但我不想让他认为我们庆祝的方式
is with the buzz that comes from caffeine does that make sense absolutely yeah those associations are so important and um in you know recognizing those behaviors and reducing them what you mentioned earlier as well about the trauma aspect of it. I mean, we see in so many cases with trauma, rates of eating disorders and direct self-harm as well and alcoholism, all of these risky behaviours. I mean, it doubles with when you add trauma to it. really important that childhood um you know the effects it can have on whether you develop these behaviors it is such an important uh time you know of someone's life and whether they'll go on to develop those for sure and i think i'm just trying to be generally more mindful about everything so i went away um in april this year to go and see Take That with my friends not necessarily because Take That were playing but because we were looking at getting together that
是靠咖啡因带来的兴奋感。这有道理吗？绝对有道理。这些联想非常重要。在识别并减少这些行为时，你之前提到的创伤方面也很重要。在许多创伤案例中，我们看到饮食失调、直接自残、酗酒等风险行为的比例很高。当加上创伤时，这些风险会加倍。童年经历对你是否会发展出这些行为有很大影响，这是一个非常重要的时期。
weekend and we're like what should we do oh Take That are playing let's do that um but I decided actually I'm not going to drink this weekend because I really want to value the time with my friends but also because I'm driving home for two hours the next day. I just don't want to ruin my night's sleep and then ruin the way that I feel the next day. Or I'm not a great drinker anyway, so I'll sometimes feel quite sick and two drinks is about as much as I can handle. But I was like, you know, what would happen if I freed myself up to not drink at all um so I didn't and one of my friends didn't either and you know that weekend has been so restorative for me I still think of it really fondly like the whole week afterwards I just felt incredible like to have
我只是试图在各方面更加留心。今年四月，我和朋友们去看Take That乐队的演唱会，不是因为他们演出，而是因为我们想聚在一起。我们问：“做什么好呢？”“哦，Take That在演出，去吧。”但我决定：“这个周末我不喝酒，因为我想珍惜和朋友在一起的时间，而且第二天我要开车两小时回家。”我不想毁了我的睡眠，也不想毁了第二天的心情。我酒量不好，有时会感到恶心，两杯就是极限。但我心想：“如果我让自己完全不喝酒会怎样？”所以我没喝，我的一个朋友也没喝。那个周末对我来说非常治愈，我至今仍怀念它。之后的一整周我都感觉棒极了，因为
had that time with my friends um you know the joyful experiences we had together that were take that related or non-take that related you know and it just had such a lasting impact that's just warmed my cockles in a way that I know it wouldn't have done had I drunk because my body and mind would have needed to recover from that energy and i think that is the gift that i've given future me to not have to do that and it's actually i've avoided indirect self-harm there brilliant yeah i mean that's a brilliant example it sounds like it's a great experience um it's definitely having that introspective awareness um like yeah I think you know psychology professionals they tend to have that awareness anyway um just from the you know
拥有了和朋友在一起的时光，那些快乐的经历。这对我来说是一种持久的影响，它温暖了我的心，如果我喝了酒，这种感觉就不会有了，因为我的身心需要从那种能量中恢复。我认为这是我给未来的自己的一份礼物，避免了间接自残。太棒了。这是一个绝佳的例子，听起来是一次很棒的经历。拥有这种内省的意识，心理学专业人士通常都有这种意识，仅仅是因为……
learning about it and so yeah having that awareness and again it comes back to who you surround yourself with so um you know your friend was it sounds she sounds really supportive um you know didn't drink either but obviously in some groups especially I think in um you know male friend groups there can be that sort of stigma around those sort of um behaviors where you know they'll say oh you know you're no fun or you know they'll kind of make fun of you and then you might feel pressured to you know oh okay then I'll have a drink um so I think yeah it's so important who you surround yourself with in that way absolutely and you know when we got together to have lunch two of my friends had
了解这一点，所以拥有这种意识，再次回到你身边的人是谁。嗯，你知道你的朋友听起来真的很支持你，她也不喝酒，但显然在某些群体中，尤其是男性朋友群体中，对于这种行为可能会有一种污名化，他们会说你真没劲，或者取笑你，然后你可能会感到压力，觉得好吧，那我也喝一杯。所以我认为你身边的人是谁真的很重要。
a glass of champagne and I considered it for a moment and I just thought you know what I know I will feel a bit wheezy headed and likely want a nap if I have it and actually that's not what I'm choosing for myself this afternoon so throwing no shade on them but they had one glass of champagne and you know that's how that went down for them and that you know they had a great time as well but yeah I think when we were in the arena like I don't also don't want to spend like nine pounds on a pint of something I don't really like anyway but yeah it just wasn't right for that occasion but I'm not saying I won't ever drink again I don't know I might you know I likely will but I'm just doing it more mindfully I guess I don't want this episode to come across really preacherly that's not at all what we're saying but we're just yeah
一杯香槟，我考虑了一会儿，但我只是想，你知道吗，我知道如果我喝了，我会感到头晕，很可能想小睡一会儿，而这实际上不是我今天下午的选择。所以我并不是在贬低他们，他们喝了一杯香槟，那是他们的选择，他们也玩得很开心。但当我们在场馆里时，我也不想花九英镑买一杯我本来就不怎么喜欢的啤酒。那不适合那个场合，但我并不是说我以后再也不会喝酒了，我不知道，我可能会喝，但我只是在更用心地做这件事。我不想让这一集听起来像是在说教，我们根本不是那个意思，我们只是在
having a curious conversation really about some of these things that we might never have considered or that we don't routinely discuss with our clients? No, definitely. Yeah, I don't want it to come across like that at all. It's mainly just kind of spreading the awareness to, you know, perhaps be more mindful of those behaviours and the effects that they can have. Obviously, a drink every now and again, it's, you know, probably not going to be particularly harmful. It's, you know, it's a bit of fun um it's when it accumulates and it starts causing those um negative effects i think that that's when you you know perhaps need to check um what it's doing for you and you know if you if you do need to alter those mindsets um but yeah generally it's just about starting that awareness off i think yeah and i think often it
进行一场好奇的对话，讨论一些我们可能从未考虑过，或者我们不常与客户讨论的事情。不，绝对不是。是的，我一点也不想让它听起来像那样。这主要是为了传播意识，也许对这些行为及其可能产生的影响更加留心。显然，偶尔喝一杯可能不会特别有害，这有点乐趣。当它积累起来并开始造成那些负面影响时，我认为那时你可能需要检查它对你有什么影响，如果你确实需要改变这些心态。但总的来说，我认为这只是关于开始这种意识。
can be really useful to take it back to the window of tolerance and to look at how we regulate ourselves when we are hyper and how we regulate ourselves when we're kind of a bit freeze or flop bit hypo aroused and actually i often find that can be a really helpful conversation with clients to think about what strategies they use to either bump themselves up or to kind of bring themselves down and many of those will be in direct self-harm but what we try to role model is actually soothing within breathing is a really great alternative to that or you know a bit of mindfulness or maybe going for a walk I find going for a run really really helpful because my knees don't seem to mind it short runs they the manage you know really really helpful um because my knees don't see my mind it's short runs they the manage um you know really really helpful for keeping me well but also shifting my mindset in a way that
回到耐受窗口，看看当我们过度兴奋时如何调节自己，以及当我们有点冻结或崩溃，即低度唤醒时如何调节自己，这真的很有用。实际上，我经常发现这与客户进行关于他们使用什么策略来提升自己或让自己平静下来的对话非常有帮助。其中许多策略是直接的自残，但我们试图树立的榜样实际上是呼吸中的自我安抚，这是一个很好的替代方案，或者做点正念，或者去散步。我发现去跑步真的非常有帮助，因为我的膝盖似乎不介意短跑，它们能应付，这对我保持健康非常有帮助，同时也以一种方式改变了我的心态，
probably is going to be better for me than a mars bar or better for me than a glass of wine and have a more lasting impact for me definitely yeah um and it comes down to I can't remember the specific term I think it's risk reduction but it's when you're you know when your client is perhaps self-harming and they you encourage them to adopt other strategies you know that might still be you know harmful in a way for example using an elastic band against your wrist instead of cutting yourself I can't remember the specific term for that now but um you know just stepping back so that you're getting the similar sensation but in a way that actually isn't going to to risk so if you if someone's liking the elastic band they're getting that sensation on their wrist without cutting their
可能比吃玛氏巧克力棒或喝一杯葡萄酒对我更好，并且对我产生更持久的影响。绝对是这样。这归结为，我不记得具体的术语了，我想是风险降低，但当你鼓励客户采用其他策略时，即使这些策略在某种程度上可能仍然是有害的，例如用橡皮筋弹手腕而不是割伤自己。我不记得那个具体的术语了，但只是退后一步，这样你就能获得类似的快感，但这种方式实际上不会造成风险。如果有人喜欢橡皮筋，他们就能在手腕上获得那种感觉，而不会割伤他们的
wrist that can open them up to kind of blood infections and and you know blood loss as well and pain and yeah um i can't remember the term either but um you know i think it's something you know yeah i do something we'll often see in um in kind of dialectical behavioral therapy as well that kind of thing so um thank you so much for your time um if people want to come and have a look at your research more fully is linkedin the best place for them to do that eva yes linkedin um i'm eva hyphen perry on linkedin um i'm happy to if you want to send me a message i'd be happy to talk to anyone um to discuss further it's an interesting subject and you know i'd really like to share you know what I found and spread that awareness for the community start a discussion
手腕，这可能会导致血液感染、失血和疼痛。是的，我也不记得那个术语了，但我认为这是我们在辩证行为疗法中经常看到的东西。非常感谢你的时间。如果人们想更全面地了解你的研究，领英是最好的地方吗，Eva？是的，领英。我在领英上是Eva-Perry。如果你想给我发信息，我很乐意与任何人交谈，进一步讨论。这是一个有趣的话题，我真的很想分享我的发现，并为社区传播这种意识，开启讨论。
yeah it really is I think it's going to be a case of watch out world for when you go on to do whatever kind of professional qualification that you do but yeah thank you for having this conversation with our audience and for demonstrating that actually really brilliant stuff goes on even at earlier stages of people's psychology career brilliant yeah thank you for having me on it's been really nice to discuss with another professional um yeah thank you you're so welcome take care of yourself and be kind to yourself and always ask someone to hoover your house should you want them to brilliant thank you what an absolute pleasure to speak with Ava please do go and follow her over on LinkedIn and I would love to know your
是的，确实如此。我想当你去完成任何专业资格认证时，世界都要小心了。但感谢你与我们的听众进行这次对话，并证明了即使在心理学职业生涯的早期阶段，也会发生非常出色的事情。太棒了，谢谢你邀请我。与另一位专业人士讨论真是太好了。谢谢你，不用客气。照顾好自己，善待自己，如果需要的话，总是请人帮你打扫房子。太棒了，谢谢。与Ava交谈真是太愉快了，请一定要在领英上关注她。我很想知道你的
thoughts about this episode do come and let me know what you think on my social media Dr. Marianne Trent I am that everywhere. But also come into the group, the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent and let me know what you think to it there. Perhaps it might be a useful one to share with your service if you think that they might find that beneficial. The Aspiring Psychologist Community is also the home of Marianne's motivation and mindset videos. So that's the only place you can watch them. So come and join and come and join in. If you enjoy the podcast, please do rate it. Please do review it. Please do subscribe, follow the show as it helps us to reach a wider audience. And it's the kindest
对这一集的想法。请在我的社交媒体上告诉我你的想法，我是Dr. Marianne Trent，到处都是这个名字。但也请加入我们的免费Facebook群组，Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent，并在那里告诉我你的想法。如果你认为你的服务机构可能会觉得有益，也许分享这一集会很有用。Aspiring Psychologist Community也是Marianne的动力和心态视频的所在地。所以那是你唯一可以观看它们的地方。所以快来加入并参与进来。如果你喜欢这个播客，请评分、评论、订阅并关注该节目，因为它能帮助我们接触到更广泛的受众。这是最友善的
thing you can do for absolutely free. If you love these kinds of growth conversations that really help you stretch and grow and think about important issues in psychology, if you think this is how good the free stuff is, imagine how good the stuff is in the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month. Do check out the details in the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month. Do check out the details in the show notes or on any of my socials or just DM me the word membership and I will be in touch with you.
你可以完全免费做的事情。如果你喜欢这些真正能帮助你扩展、成长并思考心理学重要议题的成长对话，如果你认为免费的内容就这么好，想象一下Aspiring Psychologist会员资格里的内容会有多好，你每月只需30英镑即可加入。请查看节目说明或我的任何社交媒体上的详细信息，或者直接私信我“membership”这个词，我会与你联系。
Please do come and follow me on socials. I'll often drop voice notes to new connections so you may have your very own personalised podcast episode just from me to you be kind to yourself i will look forward to bringing the next episode to you from 10 a.m on saturday for youtube and wherever you get your podcast from 6 a.m on monday take care if you're looking to become a psychologist
请一定要在社交媒体上关注我。我经常会给新联系人发送语音笔记，所以你可能会收到我为你量身定制的播客片段。善待自己，我期待在周六上午10点为YouTube带来下一集，无论你在哪里获取播客，请在周一上午6点收听。如果你正在寻求成为一名心理学家，请照顾好自己。
then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist.
那么让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是由Dr. Marianne Trent主持的Aspiring Psychologist Podcast。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《Clinical Psychologist Collective》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。
It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的成为心理学家的道路，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。